oba and the nice thing about the
supernova is we know how bright they
intrinsically are so by seeing how
bright they appear to us we can figure
out how far away they are the further
the dimmer they are the further they are
away what you've done this in the 1990s
two independent teams of astronomers
succeeded in doing this and they both
got the same answer the answer is that
if you look at the galaxy right now and
waited a billion years a billion years
from now will be moving away from us
faster the universe is not just getting
bigger it is accelerating and this was
in 1998 the breakthrough of the year for
science magazine a little picture of
Albert Einstein blowing up universes in
his pipe that's what makes you the man
of the century when you can blow up
universes in your pipe people are very
excited about this but they didn't
necessarily believe it it's a remarkable
claim you want some way of checking how
do you check this how do you check this
idea that seventy percent of the
universe is not just darn but it's not
even matter it's not even particles it's
something that is intrinsic to space
itself well gravitational lensing once
again gives us the answer but instead of
measuring and weighing the amount of
stuff in a cluster you measure the whole
universe all at once this is another
NASA satellite the Wilkinson microwave
anisotropy probe w map it took pictures
of the universe when it was four hundred
thousand years after the Big Bang a tiny
little baby universe and what you do is
just look at the size of the ripples of
the universe in that period and those
will be bigger or smaller compendium
'try of the universe the answer is that
the geometry of the universe is flat but
the amount of matter in the universe
both ordinary matter and dark matter is
not enough to explain why the universe
is flat it is perfectly well explained
if you believe in dark energy so a
completely independent line of reasoning
has led us to believe that seventy
percent of the universe is dark energy
it's making the universe accelerate that
fact made a prediction that the universe
would be flat we went out and measured
it and it is flattened so in 2003 the
breakthrough of the year was the fact
that we hadn't made a mistake w map went
and confirmed this crazy idea this
inventory of the universe is
sufficiently surprising that figuring
out it's true as a break
true and making sure it's right is also
a breakthrough so there we are this is
what we've accomplished in the last 10
or 20 years of cosmology we finally
figured out an inventory for what the
universe is made of the problem is it's
a little bit surprising we don't know
why this is seventy percent this is
twenty-five percent this is five percent
these numbers change as a function of
time the dark energy doesn't go away as
the universe expands it's a constant
energy density in every cubic centimeter
but the matter does go away so the past
the matter was winning in the future
we'll have almost nothing in the
universe but dark energy this is a very
satisfying story from an observational
point of view a very challenging story
from a theoretical point of view and a
completely irrelevant story from a
political point of view or so you would
think but I'm going to take the
challenge of getting moral to this story
the interesting fact about this story is
that it puts us in our place we live in
a universe where only five percent of
the stuff in the universe is the same
kind of stuff that we are made of we are
not what the universe is about we are
the olive in the martini which is not
what the martini is about we are the
blinking lights on the Christmas tree we
are not the substance of what is going
on so this is an interesting fact about
the universe that we would never have
been led to if we just SAT around and
thought this is a story that is forced
on us by going out there collecting data
and dealing with it and I want to
contrast that way of thinking with no
booze here a movie you may be familiar
with called what the bleep do we know
this is a movie someone had the bright
idea of making a movie about quantum
mechanics so I applaud them for their
foot spot when it comes to that but the
problem is this movie is full of
nonsense the movie tries to get across
the message that what quantum mechanics
teaches us is that we can change the
nature of physical reality by thinking
about it that by putting ourselves in
the right mental state we can make the
real world what we want it to be
after the movie came out the filmmakers
were all given high ranking jobs in the
bush administration I'm not for how that
happened david albert is a philosopher
of science at columbia university and he
appeared in the movie and he's an
extremely sensible person who knows
what's going on basically he was
snookered into appearing in the movie
they interviewed him for four hours and
took ten second snippets out of that
where he says no yes that's very
interesting when the movie came out he
was outraged how he was portrayed in the
movie and went around giving talks to
people who liked this movie he tried to
explain to them what was going on and
the David would basically say this look
when you're trying to understand the
world there are two approaches you can
have one kind of approach is that when
you try to look at the world you come
with a precondition you come with a set
of demands that the world tell a story
that is flattering to you the other
thing you could do is to come with an
authentically open mind and open heart
and expend many different hypotheses and
compare them to the evidence and accept
what the evidence tells you discard the
hypotheses that don't fit the evidence
and believe in the hypotheses that do
and that second method is called science
and I would like to say
that it's more than that that second
method is called honesty and it probably
is a good method used in all sorts of
fields of human endeavor science is one
of them but they're probably others that
you can also think of so in the end
however I think nevertheless despite the
fact that we're good scientists the
universe has managed to tell us a
flattering story about ourselves here is
the Hubble Deep Field with all those
galaxies this little insert is an image
of the earth as seen from the Voyager
satellite as it was leaving the solar
system in February 1990 there we are a
pale blue dot that is an insignificant
little piece of this wide universe most
of which is completely invisible to us
nevertheless despite the fact that we
are this tiny little piece in this very
very vast cosmos over just a couple
hundred years a few thousand years of
thinking and collecting data and dealing
with it we have managed to come to
understand a great deal about how this
universe is working we have managed to
extend our imaginations and our
instruments across the stretches of
space and learn a lot about a universe
that is a lot bigger than we are and
it's that kind of fact that make gives
me hope that there may be some hope for
us in the end after all thank